[Music]
final exam was canceled last night due
to breaking news from North Korea but we
still held the competition because
that's how we are here's what happened
oh you're at a time it's time for final
exam where two news professionals face
one another in a battle of knowledge you
can play along at home as they do
joining us tonight fox chief national
correspondent ed Henry he won the battle
of defending champions last week against
Bret Baier quite a contest he gets to
return for another matchup his
challenger this week
Fox Washington correspondent old friend
Jillian Turner tisha you booked on the
rules but for the sake of consistency
and because judges demand it here they
are handsome buzzers I ask the questions
first wind abuzz and gets to answer you
have to wait until I finish asking the
question in order to do that every
correct answer is worth the point if you
get it wrong we deduct a point from your
total best of five wins
clear it's International Women's Day
it's these are the international rules -
I just thought that you might want to
mention that right absolutely and that
does not give you the first question
after winning the Academy Award for Best
Actress on Sunday night Frances McDorman
had something unusual happened to her
Oscar what was it ed Henry some guys
stole it or I believe that some guys
stole it making this up roll tape to
quote some guys steal it this morning
Terri Bryant isn't celebrating instead
charged with grand theft larceny after
allegedly swiping the Best Actress Oscar
winner Frances McDorman and what's the
long-term plan when you steal an Oscar
the hope your friends didn't notice you
didn't
you can't post some guy stole it indeed
you were right I don't know what his job
was but he was backstage or something
wasn't Warren Beatty it's worth about $8
at the little Matt I didn't get that
because I watched that I'd watch larceny
backstage no larceny didn't happen in
real time exactly question to one of the
world's most popular sodas announced
this week they'll soon be selling their
first ever alcoholic drink what company
is it soda maker selling booze care to
guess give us a hint you that's that's
the judges have a hint but I think it's
too okay I'll give it based in Atlanta
ed Henry coca-cola he says is it Coca
Cola or could it be 7up breaking into
the booze business and more than a
hundred thirty years this is gonna be
caught too and of course the trick was
in Japan right but I didn't say that no
you didn't you got Coca Cola all right
yeah you both got the hint to be fair
though by the way let me just say I am I
am rooting for you I've never admitted
that okay
don't blame me question three it's
Saturday's Saturday's grid iron dinner
at which Brett Barrett by the way played
a starring role the president roasted
Washington elite he zeroed in on one
congresswoman for her claim that we can
secure our southern border by mowing the
grass there what member of Congress did
he target ed Henry Nancy Pelosi Nancy no
you see you're saying that Nancy Pelosi
claimed we could yeah tighten our Bors
nodded iron but I did a story on this
for Shannon okay we'll see if your
memory serves we have a responsibility
to protect our borders should there be
fencing should there be technology
should we should they mow the grass so
that people can hide in it why don't you
really really said that and we have the
tape okay you can still turn it around
by the way Jillian
she can't I just can't answer anymore
because I'll lose points in just okay
well you'll see if you can get this one
question for a zoo in Indonesia is being
criticized by animal rights activists a
video emerged this week showing an
orangutan at the zoo doing something
only adult humans typically do what was
it and hint are you ready hence the
Surgeon General disapproves Gillian
Turner smoke he was smoking a cigarette
zoo just look you can see Odin puffing
away like an experienced smoker he knows
what to do it's crazy a visitor through
the lit cigarette at the primates
enclosure in Indonesia
officials say he likely learned how to
smoke from watching humans crazy but who
gave him the cigarette I don't know but
they're hassling him he has to stand
outside the building when he smokes now
people look down on him I mean really
anyway
final question if you drive by
McDonald's today there's a chance you
might see the famed golden arches turned
upside down to form a W who is the
fast-food chain honoring Jillian Turner
women you don't think it's George W Bush
it might be but you say women but I'm
going with women going with women is it
women today is International Women's Day
and there it is on your screen
McDonald's has flipped the arches
they've turned the em upside down it's a
W for women as a woman did you eat a Big
Mac today I did not you did not but I
was touched Wow
you know what this is one of those games
that had to going on one more round it
might have been a little different
chilling I mean if it wasn't rigged you
were great studied all the anti bow this
you're the only person with that book
there is an inscription to add 9/11 2003
not really a reporter I'd never want on
my tail best Tucker Carlson is that true
Henry knife known each other a long time
that's my handwriting
that's unbelievable found it this week
your book coming out soon 15 years ago
Eddie Henry by the way speaking of
journalism we're gonna give you the
coveted Eric whemple mug it shows our
friend Eric wemble for the Washington
Post and is one appearance on our show
and then of course our triumphant
response thank you thank you please come
back welcome your Fox we'll see you next
week